okay
very quickly
trump's approval has plunged to its
lowest in a year
now i'm going to show you what the
number is and the number is actually
kind of scary newsweek reports donald
trump's approval rating plunges to
lowest point in over a year this is
based on an nbc news poll 54
negative approval rating and 34 positive
for trump
okay
trump had the same 54 negative in august
but a slightly higher positive of 36.
trump also had 36 positive in may and
march 37 in january okay doesn't matter
so there's two things going on here
number one
clearly to some degree
the country is reacting
to the absurdity of what this man has
become it's a joke
complete and total joke and more and
more people have moved away from trump
that's a good thing
the scary thing is
how insane is this country
that more than a third of the country
still approves of trump
who has now been out of office for
20 months
who
has apparently done so many things that
go against the fundamentals of what this
country is based on both in spirit and
in practice when it comes to the law
humiliates us regularly and himself on
the world stage still as a former
president
and more than a third of the country
when ass says i think i think trump's
great i i highly approve of trump yeah
he's fantastic
and there is a um
there's an excerpt from a book written
after world war ii that describes how
just ordinary germans
in nazi germany
descended into a state where there was
relatively high approval of hitler and
his uh nazi regime
and um you can google this it's uh
the university of chicago
has an excerpt from it the book is they
thought they were free the germans
1933-1940
the book is by milton mayer
and there's an excerpt called but then
it was too late
and it talks about the slow descent into
yeah i mean i guess i do approve even
though if you if we now went back six
years and described what trump is now
you wouldn't say would you approve of
that you wouldn't get 34 or 36 approval
you wouldn't but there's this slow
descent slow descent into madness
one other piece
i think
is a good idea to read if you want to
understand what's going on is by alex
shepherd in new republic it's called
donald trump is more deranged than ever
as his approval ratings sink the
president is more and more unhinged and
more willing to indulge his most
dangerous followers and that's very
relevant to you know we saw this q anon
moment during trump's ohio rally over
the weekend also extraordinarily
dangerous
that article which we will link to
instructive and informative and very
very scary let's take a quick break
we're going to be right back after this